la detención arbitraria y
discriminatoria de los uigures en china
podría constituir crímenes de lesa
humanidad según la onu en conclusión las
descripciones de las detenciones en el
período comprendido entre 2017 y 2019
recopilados por la alta comisionada para
los derechos humanos estuvieron marcados
por patrones de tortura u otras formas
de trato cruel el informe fue presentado
por la alta comisionada de las naciones
unidas para los derechos humanos
michelle bachelet a tan sólo unos
minutos de dejar su cargo y tras
enfrentar duras críticas por su postura
blanda con china
mi esperanza es que su sucesor sea
fuerte de mentalidad independiente que
no se deje intimidar fácilmente por
nadie
china es acusada de abusos contra los
uigures una minoría étnica de unas 10
millones de personas mayoritariamente
musulmana que vive en la región
occidental de xinjiang en los que entre
el 10 y el 20% fueron sometidos a
trabajos forzados en campos de
concentración y a otras violaciones de
derechos humanos entre 2017 y 2018
bachelet confirmó la semana pasada haber
recibido una carta de beijing que le
pedía enterrar el informe la misiva
estaba firmada por unos 40 estados más
pero dijo que su oficina no respondería
a tales presiones china niega las
acusaciones
nos oponemos firmemente a tales reportes
todos sabemos que el llamado problema de
xinjiang es completamente una mentira
fabricada con motivos políticos su
propósito es minar la estabilidad china
y obstruir el desarrollo chino falta
comisionado de los derechos humanos
deben mantenerse independiente y evitar
intervenir en los asuntos internos de
china y no debe resignarse a la presión
de la política de poder de varios países
occidentales la onu recomienda el
gobierno chino que también medidas
rápidas para liberar a todos los
detenidos en centros de formación
prisiones o centros de detención